moi je pense que oui au vu des derniers
chiffres d'aujourd'hui la sur le variant
qui normalement devrait exposer de
manière exponentielle
je pense qu'il vaudrait mieux y aller
franchement pas attendre d'être au bord
du gouffre bah je pense que le un
confinement même dieu de 2 un mois mais
street avait plus défié que que
n'importe quoi non je suis pas certain
je pense qu'aujourd'hui les règles qui
sont mises en place sont suffisantes
ensuite après c'est chacun doit gérer
deux ça doit avoir son avis en fonction
des risques qui le prend et d'être en
mesure de de savoir si chacun d'être
conscient de ce qu'il veut de ce qu'ils
feront comme risques pour limiter la
propagation du virus
je pense que il est pas forcément obligé
d'en faire des tas par rapport à ça mais
je pense que il peut avoir des mesures
ou qu'elle est un peu plus qu'on a fait
sa structure et par rapport à la
population française auquel on peut se
mettre en place et on peut tous se
mettre d'accord mais bon après ça c'est
quelque chose
d'où c'est le gouvernement qui s'en
occupent tout ce système tous et de
l'apesa cette restriction qu'ils ont mis
en place dont en france
je pense vraiment que on a bien compris
on a tous compris que ce qu'on voit là
ça nous a tous sont autrement entre
guillemets marques et marchés n'ont pas
partagé parce qu'en fait j'ai des amis
qui travaillent dans les hôpitaux je
sais que l'association est très très
compliqué mais en même temps tous les
côtés de d'étudiants des personnes âgées
qui sont 66 logique très très très
compliqué donc je peux partager entre
les deux côtés je ne sais pas au cancer
est la meilleure solution mais bon et
pas un autre co finalement je crois sur
l'autre confinement ça peut être très
très dur
en tout le sens économiquement puisque
le chemin y voilà je suis partagé parce
que je pense que l'état fait pas trop
trop belle ce qui fait c'est vrai que
idéalement écouter les autorités
médicales il faudrait faire plus pour
être plus efficace plus vite et éviter
que la suite soit complexe
cela étant économiquement bah je vais
dire j'ai enfoncé une porte ouverte
économiquement on sait bien qu'on filme
en coûte quoi 15 milliards d'euros à
l'état tous les mois et tout s'accumule
et je crains qu'on ait jamais l'occasion
de rattraper tout ça par rapport à
nouveau sur moi j'en du québec a plus
vraiment de pression là pour toi et nous
régale vraiment pas que kevin 19
non je pense vraiment franchement qu'ici
on aurait vraiment laissez nulle part
ailleurs et personnes sans masque sans
masque bon une petite amende
ceci est distribuée via la rue gel
antibactérien un soliste seither un peu
partout comme sautois plaisir à présent
complètement complètement
je suis d'accord avec toi ainsi plus de
répression car plusieurs essais
parapente au tout c'est vraiment
important de bien servir et mais des
amendes la répression quoi
arrivé au niveau européen au niveau
mondial ensemble relaxé quand même donc
je crois que tous les pays devraient
faire quelque chose pour nous faire
vivre mais aussi pour faire respecter
les règles parce que je pense que et
l'agencé anp peut relaxer voilà
respecter des règles voilà c'est pas
forcément à voir ces libertés coupé mais
si on fait plus de contrôle peut-être
qu'on peut faire plus de choses
voilà qu'en général je ne suis pas du
tout pour la répression mais on est dans
un cas de force majeure et
malheureusement malheureusement pas tout
le monde mais souvent les gens ont
besoin de règles strictes et surtout de
contraventions quand ça touche les plus
portefeuille surtout un alors à ce
moment là oui ça marche ça marche il est
en tout cas c'est dommage mais c'est
comme ça non je pense qu'il faudrait
plus de liberté plus parce que là on est
dans ce sens déjà réprimer tout le temps
tout le temps enfermé tout le temps
obligé de respecter les règles et ça
fait un an qu'on respecte je pense que
là on a besoin de souffler en fait